at least 13 of the 33 parents charged in
the massive College Admission scheme
will appear in a Boston courtroom today
that are expected to enter pleas on
conspiracy charges this comes one day
after a key defendant former Yale soccer
coach Rudy Meredith became the third
person in the case to plead guilty
Carter Evans is at the Boston federal
courthouse guard a good morning good
morning the parents expected to appear
in court today are really just the first
group the rest including actresses
Felicity Huffman and Lori Lachlan will
be here next Wednesday this after the
man whose actions exposed the scandal
admitted his wrongdoing if you have
anything to say to the student you
helped get into Yale former Yale soccer
coach Rudy Meredith didn't say a word as
he left a Boston courthouse Thursday
surrounded by a crush of cameras inside
the 51 year old pleaded guilty to
pocketing more than eight hundred sixty
thousand dollars in bribes to help
parents get their children into Yale
court documents show that in 2017 Rick
singer the mastermind behind the scheme
paid Meredith four hundred thousand
dollars to get the daughter of a wealthy
couple into the Ivy League school
Meredith designated her as one of his
recruits even though she had never
played competitive soccer this week Yale
announced it's rescinding that student's
admission Yale students are in Boston
covering the scandal for the school
paper do you think what happened here
today will bring any closure to this I
mean I hope so I think the the biggest
amount of closure that a lot of students
would like to see is just a confirmation
that they that everyone at Yale got into
Yale fairly Meredith's downfall
apparently came when he tried to work a
deal on his own
according to federal authorities he
directly sought out $450,000 in bribes
last year from a wealthy father but that
parent was already under investigation
by federal authorities for securities
fraud and the father tipped off the FBI
ultimately exposing singer's
wide-ranging $25,000,000 scheme it's
clear by all of this that we need reform
in California Thursday lawmakers
proposed a series of measures aimed at
keeping college applicants from cheating
the system including requiring
three college administrators to sign off
on special admissions and banning
special treatment for children of donors
or alumni we want to put faith back into
the admissions policy that if you work
hard you have a fair shot because right
now you don't among the parents expected
here today are a couple accused of
paying $200,000 to fake their daughter's
volleyball records and a father who
allegedly paid $75,000 to have his son's
a CT test answers corrected I'm Rudy
Meredith is going to be back in court
June 20th for sentencing that is one day
after Rick's singer's sentencing
Tony Carter thank you a reminder that
where you go to college does not
determine everything about the rest of
your life take some of the pressure off
here yes